bienvenue dans neuf
un jeu qui ressemble à action ou vérité
mais sans la vérité
les voyeurs paie pour voir les joueurs
jouent pour gagner l'argent et la gloire
situé voyeur aux joueurs tu es wire
joueur tu es voyage ça a l'air très
louche non reste que c'est légal il faut
que tu prennes des risques une fois de
temps en temps mais j'en prends des
risques
ok tu vas jouer à neuf vitu accepte
tandis brasser un inconnu pendant 5
secondes
en brasse ce gala qui
ok ok bah il semble que les voyeurs
veulent que je fasse équipe avec toi ok
et vous
nous avons je peux trouver cette robe
foulard
mon portefeuille mes fringues tout a
disparu je sais mais à faire aussi ce
que ça dit c'est qu'on doit juste
quitter le magasin
sans elle je suis fan
oui
ce qu'est un gosse qui est mort à
seattle en jouant un honneur il fait
quoi qu'il ait fait tu perds tous les
fouilleurs ont volé notre identité on
est devenu prisonnier du jour j nous
contrôlons avis le seul moyen de s'en
sortir cette date il voulait pas que
tuer mes yeux je ne crois pas
joueurs montrer nos jours
qu'est ce que je vais pas bien
cabaye
non mais
rose
et que 16 des solutions
son effet
m
eh oui